there is a billionaire nba executive he
is a part owner of the
of the warriors the golden state
warriors in california in san francisco
his name is chamath palihapatia
okay so forgive me if i screwed up the
name and he was doing a podcast and i
have to say one of the most amazing
things about people who are
extraordinarily wealthy is that very
often they really think they know things
they do not know there's a famous line
from fiddler on the roof you know when
you're rich they think you really know
but but the truth is for some people
when they are very very very rich like
not just fu rich but f the whole world
rich
they start to think that they know all
the things they know everything about
politics they know everything about
world affairs they don't have to have
studied anything because after all the
proof is in the pudding and they are
worth a lot of money and they are not
even bound by the strictures of basic
morality and decency the reason that i
bring this up with regard to this
billionaire is because this billionaire
nba owner
who's the owner of one of the most
virtue signaling organizations in
america right the warriors whose coach
is steve kerr who is a very left-wing
guy he's virtue signaled on everything
from black lives matter to donald trump
the the team is is a very left-leaning
team on everything from gay rights to
transgenderism right that the entire
social sort of
place of this team is to represent the
far left
the owner of this team he came out on a
podcast and he said he does not care
about the chinese users as specifically
about the nba's relationship with china
and he says it just straight out now
what's amazing about this is that he has
the gall to say this openly on a podcast
like this isn't leaked audio it's not as
though he said this secretly on a phone
call and then it leaked into the public
eye
he said this into a microphone on a
podcast he knew was being taped and he
apparently thought that this was a
perfectly moral thing to do and say
which is pretty incredible it really is
for for somebody who lives on the left
and i'm sure knows of the strictures of
cancellation it's amazing that he felt
comfortable enough to say this directly
into a microphone but it does show what
the left actually believes about china
and its predations on the world stage so
here is what this billionaire nba
executive chamath paliapatia had to say
about the chinese
destruction of the uyghur community in
zhang jiang
nobody cares about what's happening to
the weakers okay you you bring it up
because you really care and i think what
do you mean
the rest of us don't care i'm just
telling you a very hard you're saying
you virtually don't care i'm telling you
a very hard ugly truth okay of all the
things that i care about yes it is below
my line
okay of all the things that i care about
it is below my line
okay that's an amazing statement it's
below his line now what's amazing about
that too is that he then continued along
these lines what was above his line what
he said was above his line was climate
change so climate change was somehow
above his line but the the
imprisonment and concentration camps of
a million people by the chinese is below
his line
he said i care about yeah i care about
the fact that our economy could turn on
a time if china invades taiwan i care
about that i care about climate change
you know i care about a bunch i care
about america's crippling and decrepit
healthcare infrastructure but if you're
asking me do i care about a segment of a
class of people in another country not
until we can take care of ourselves will
i prioritize them over us and i think a
lot of people believe that and i'm sorry
if that's a hard truth to hear but every
time i say i care about the uyghurs i'm
really just lying if i don't really care
and so i'd rather not lie to you and
tell you the truth it's not a priority
for me
he said until america actually cleans up
our own house the idea that we step
outside of our borders with you know a
sort of morally virtue signaling about
somebody else's human rights track
record is deplorable it's deplorable
this is by the way how the left things
the left in the united states believes
that the united states is the root of
all evil and so we must spend all of our
time naval gazing about the evils of the
united states while simultaneously
allowing him to do business in china
which is really what this is about see
when when folks on the left talk about
climate change very often they don't
really mean they care very much about
climate change they're happy to take
their private shots they're more than
happy to consume extraordinary amounts
of carbon and create massive carbon
emissions climate change is just an
excuse to show that you care about
things that you don't actually care
about it's an excuse to say you're a
good person it is the ultimate virtue
signal it's like save the whales in the
1970s at the way that you demonstrated
to the world that you cared about things
even if you were enjoying your
highfalutin lifestyle let's just say
that you wanted to save the wells then
it became safe to bat right for a little
while it was safe to bat
which actually was a pretty good cause
i mean listen i like whales too but
let's be real about this the vast
majority of people who are slapping a
save the whale's bumper sticker on the
back of their car or then consuming
inordinate amounts of plastic and then
dumping them into the ocean so this this
silly thing that you see people like
chumath palapatia saying i don't care
about a million uyghurs in slavery in
china what i do care about is climate
change you have bullcrap i don't think
you care about climate change either i
don't think you care about any of these
things i think what you care about is
virtue signaling to your own left wing
base while being able to do business
with the people who make you richer
which is what this is really about
the reason that he is saying he doesn't
care about this is so that he can defend
china and so that he can rip on the
united states if your moral compass is
so skewed you spend all day long talking
about the evils of the country that has
made you rich and famous
and allowed you ownership of a major
sports franchise while simultaneously
pooh-poohing the human rights violations
of the chinese communist party some of
the worst human rights violations in
human history
this chinese communist party is
responsible for the death 40 million
people in the great leap forward
responsible for the for the yearly
forced abortion of hundreds of thousands
millions of children over the course of
decades
responsible now for the subjection of
the entire population of hong kong to
shear tyranny the imprisonment of a
million weakers and threats to taiwan
right that that doesn't bother you at
all but climate change is your pr i
don't believe you
i don't believe i don't think you're
being perfectly honest i think if you
were perfectly honest what you'd say is
you don't care about the weaker and you
also don't claire about care about
climate change and you also you also
don't care about the social justice
warrior nonsense what you actually care
about is getting very wealthy and
demonstrating to your friends at the
cocktail parties that you're really
really
well versed and
in these in the demands of woke culture
and like he continued along these lines
again he says quote look at the number
of black and brown men that are
incarcerated for absolutely ridiculous
crimes i don't know if you saw this past
week there's a person released from jail
because he couldn't even be protected in
jail because in some of these cells they
run these fight clubs inside of rikers
that are basically tacitly tacitly
endorsed by the corrections officers
that didn't do that don't do anything
so if you want to talk about the human
rights of people i think we have a
responsibility to take care of our own
backyard first first and then we can go
and basically morally tell other people
how they should be running their own
countries uh no i'm pretty sure that we
don't actually have to fix the problems
at rikers island to point out that
killing that taking a million people of
a different religion and shoving them
into a concentration camp and forcing
them to live in slavery
and forcibly sterilizing their women i
i'm pretty sure that no matter what
happens at rikers we can say that's bad
see the thing is that this is something
that the
folks on the radical left they love to
do they love to claim that you're a
hypocrite if you say that we should look
at human rights in china
but you haven't taken care of all your
own problems at home first
now what they are really doing is saying
you shouldn't have any standards at all
on the global stage
because no matter what the antecedent is
the consequent in the sentence is going
to be so we shouldn't pay attention to
the uyghurs and the reason for that is
because he's making a lot of money off
the chinese
it comes down to money
i mean this is a cynical take but it's
real for the nba
for the lebron james's and for the
chamath palais it comes down to the cold
hard cash
and shamath continued along these lines
he said because it wasn't just enough to
say listen china's got its problems
we've got our problems we should solve
our problems first he then continued by
actively downplaying the dictatorship of
xi jinping in china
i'm not even sure that that it just
china is a dictatorship the way that you
want to call it that
again i think
that's in the name look you have to
understand jason there are a set of
checks and balances here on china that
you know at the end of the day i don't
think that i have the moral absolutism
to judge china and i would say that when
nato is silent the united nations is
silent all of western europe is silent
and america is effectively silent that
this issue may be
small data points being extrapolated in
a way to create a narrative that maybe
not be true
did xi jinping write this guy like in a
lab this is unbelievable stuff by the
way the reason the united nations is
silent is because china is on the
security council they can veto anything
it's like saying you know the u.n is
really silent about russian predations
in crimea yeah because russia can veto
anything on the security council
you want to know why the eu is silent on
china because the eu will do whatever it
can in order to keep china in its corner
the same way this guy will
the the dirty little secret about the
opening of china is that china used
capitalism to worm its way into power in
a wide variety of countries
by making its market dependent on the
rest of the world kowtowing to it and
the rest of the world went well okay
well i guess i we can't care anymore
about them doing evil things as long as
we can sell cheap product in china and
manufacture cheap products in china
it really is an incredible thing
right the the response
from from
shamath is is pretty insane
it really is
you know the the the
belief system that america is so evil
that we have nothing to say about
chinese predations i i would i wouldn't
believe it if he said it
and i really don't believe when he's
making money off of china so the
warriors then put out a statement about
chama palapatiya's statement quote as a
limited investor who has no day-to-day
operating functions with the warriors mr
palapita does not speak on behalf of our
franchise and his views certainly don't
reflect those of our organization
okay i noticed a few words that you
didn't mention in that statement golden
state warriors you didn't use the word
china and you didn't use the word wieger
i noticed that by the way he then put
out a statement trying to walk this back
and his statement trying to walk this
back is egregiously vague quote in
re-listening to this week's podcast i
recognize that i come across as lacking
empathy i acknowledge that entirely as a
refugee my family fled a country with
its own set of human rights issues so
this is something that is very much a
part of my lived experience to be clear
my belief is that human rights matter
whether in china the united states or
elsewhere full stop
well
no that's not your belief now i think
you're lying
i also noticed that you didn't mention
the chinese uyghurs anywhere in that
statement
and the problem here is not a lack of
empathy the problem here is that
you just
value your cash more than you value
actual values and this is true for so
many of these it's amazing how many
virtue signaling companies in the united
states
all these companies that are using
virtue signaling to market because let's
p let's be frank about this during the
black lives matter protest of 2020 when
the corporate world dumped 23
billion with ab dollars into various
causes promoted by black lives matter
that was a payoff it was a pure
corporate payoff it was an attempt to
get all of the woksters to leave them
alone it was an attempt not only that to
capitalize on the wokesters it was an
attempt to say to the black community of
the united states which the media
assured us was 100 behind defund the
police which of course is not true
those corporations attempting to appeal
to a particular demographic by throwing
money at the problem and pretending that
they as a corporate culture had moved
into woke territory so leave us alone
and allow us to make our money and not
only that why don't you spend money with
us because if you spend money with us
then you're backing the cause
when it comes to china however the
problem is they're making more money off
of china than they are losing money from
people in the united states who refuse
to do business with them this is a very
simple business calculation for all
these businesses including the nba
including chamath pelahipatia
and the calculation is this if they rip
china china cuts off the market
if they don't rip china china leaves the
market open and the number of people in
the united states who are upset enough
to turn off an nba game is enos canter
right the those are the that is the
total number of people in the united
states who care enough and this is why
he's gonna get away with this he'll say
it and it won't be a problem lebron
james hell said it and no one cared
because either they're right and no one
cares about the weakers or as it turns
out most people just want to watch
basketball and they can get away with
nearly anything but that should
demonstrate full scale how cynical they
are when it comes to their other causes
too
it's not that they care about black
lives matter and they don't care about
the weakers they don't care about any of
these things they don't care about any
of these things they are pure money
making machines
so the question becomes if you're on the
right or if you're just an american who
doesn't like chinese predations the
question becomes
why are you falling for it
right either you push back or these
folks are going to
do whatever is most
on their bottom line whatever makes
their bottom line the strongest is what
they are going to do which means virtue
signaling to the woke because the woke
are willing to
number one
leave the profit margins of the mba
alone so long as the nba
does its performative ritual malice
struggle sessions on race
so they can they can make money there
and they can make money in china as long
as they don't piss off the chinese so if
you actually want the nba to change its
behavior
then you're going to have to
push on the other side you're going to
say to the nba no
no we are not going to patronize your
games no we are not going to spend money
on the warriors no we are not going to
buy your gear
you have to become as militant
on the on the pro america side as so
many on the left are on the anti-america
side
because right now
you have a complete imbalance of power a
complete imbalance of power when it
comes to the right and the left when it
comes to corporate america in this
country the left can manipulate
corporate america by
trying to exert pressure
both market pressure and regulatory
pressure and the right sits they're like
well we'll buy whatever product is
necessary this is why i've said there
must be some sort of mutually assured
destruction that is brought to bear on
these massive companies now mutually
assured destruction must say either you
guys stay completely apolitical and you
stay out of politics entirely or you're
going to get clocked because if you move
to the left you'll get clocked by the
right and if you move to the right
you'll get clocked by the left
and then there'll be a neutrality that
is put in place and so that has to
happen from a popular level in the
united states but there's something else
that has to happen here and that is that
the west has to start seeing china as
the threat that it is because it's not
just that china is a military threat
it's not just that china has a huge
military arsenal and they're pointing it
at places like taiwan and they're
attempting to choke off the south china
sea and they're attempting to affect
shipping straits and they are
threatening australia right that's not
just the problem with china the problem
with china is that they are militarizing
our own institutions against us
because china has realized the game
they've been able to weaponize the power
of capitalism in order to pervert all
the businesses that want to do business
in china
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang